a man and you think you're something  you're not it's a ticking Time Bomb  until Society teaches you a lesson  that's the difference this is why men in  general are more self-accountable  because the men who are not  self-accountable get [ __ ] up so those  who are successful are very  self-accountable people they look at  themselves and go okay the only way I'm  going to get and progress further the  reason she left me the only way I'm  going to do better make more money Etc  et cetera is I have to change most women  don't want to do that they don't sit and  think I have to change they think oh he  left me because it's him and I lost my  job because my boss and this is this  because of this they're not your women  don't look in the mirror and change a  [ __ ] thing yeah